allora signora delle
here is the elected candidate for the
presidency of the Commission elected
just a few minutes ago as you have seen
this journey ended this morning when ms
von der Leyen gave a speech
for us in the European Parliament there
were lot of commitments and important
commitments in that speech which we
settled of storing we had an exchange
very transparent between political
groups parliamentarians and ms von der
Leyen
now we wanted to set the priorities for
the start of this next period in the
Parliament and for the new Commission so
this journey ended today but as you know
it will carry on because miss Wanda
Lyons task begins this evening and of
course the Parliament is very much there
to make sure that we carry on with the
same transparency as we've had a lot so
a lot of meeting a lot of dialogue and a
lot of understanding of the issues here
the the institutions need to put into
this to make sure that this
parliamentary term is important for our
citizens so there's a lot of hope here
we have come out of the elections with
the strength of our citizens who want
more Europe and I think that all of the
institutions need to concentrate on
reaching that objective I'll keep it
that because this press conference is
for miss von der Leyen I'd like to wish
her all the best in her work but we'll
see each other again soon when you take
up office
and we will see each other here again
all the best for reviewing your work you
so much thank you so much so much you
see me still overwhelmed these were
definitely the most intense two weeks in
my political life and first of all I
want to thank I want to thank the
president of the European Parliament
I just have been thanking the members of
the European Parliament the group
leaders I want to thank the Commission
and my fantastic transition team without
whom I wouldn't have been able to make
it through the last two weeks because as
you know it were just two weeks to speed
up to present the guidelines the
political guidelines that will now be
the frame for our wake working program
for the next five years in the European
Union and to win trust and confidence of
the members of parliament I think we
have now a good starting point in the
Parliament in the next commission with a
council I want to move Europe forward
within the next five years to a climate
front friendly Europe a climate friendly
continent a Europe that serves people
and economically strong and digital
Europe and the Europe that is based on
the rule of law with Vivid democracy
I will now work on my work program for
the next month and of course I want to
form a team highly dedicated to take
place in this endeavor we want to start
together therefore today I'm launching
my call again for leaders to present the
best candidates as European
commissioners as possible and I want to
see as many men as women around the
college table tomorrow I'm gonna be in
Germany to bid farewell to my government
my troops and then I'm looking forward
to plunge into the word here in Brussels
to spend my summer here in Brussels or
Strasbourg thank you very much
so questions from your side please this
one your couch Avicii not the good
evening president a question in French
you'll be a brussels resident soon feel
free to answer in English though
congratulations in the morning you gave
a speech which was presenting a fairly
persuasive program you got a lot of
congratulations for that but you just
scraped through with nine votes above
the absolute minimum whereas the two
main families amount to some four
hundred eighty votes so what does this
mean in terms of the support you enjoy
in your program
what does it mean to be to be elected
with 483 votes as opposed to 410 or four
four four well a majority is a majority
in politics as the president I didn't
have a majority when I came two weeks
ago people didn't know me and there as I
can understand was a great deal of
resentment surrounding the Schmitz and
candidate process and as me you've seen
the need to work with the political
groups in order to persuade them and to
put together a work program for the five
years to come I am extremely happy today
that after two weeks not even two weeks
13 days we've managed to forge a
pro-european majority I think that's a
sound foundation to start with I know
that I will have to and I wish to work
with this Parliament constructively
because there are major tasks which need
to be made a success of
two weeks earlier I could not have
believed that I would have got to this
stage so happily congratulations Madame
Enrique servitor from Spanish newspaper
everything the question I've got three
questions how do you interpret the fact
that it's so far
been for the votes of the Polish vana
government a party that
isn't that certain of wanting to be part
of Europe that you wouldn't have had a
majority what do you think about that
well personally speaking your father was
a an official of the Commission how how
would he think about that as you bring
the presence of the Commission and the
first woman sir well on that score I'm
very moved
because this morning one of my friends
at the Parliament said your father is
watching now I know he was a director
general here we moved to Germany because
he wanted to return as a commissioner
now history wanted things to go
otherwise but for me it was like coming
home always wanted to work for Europe
and in the European Union and I think I
could win the trust and the confidence
of the council and here of the majority
because over the last I think it's 15
years now being a minister in Germany
I've always worked in Europe because it
is my passion so it's a feeling like
coming home for me ginsa Bakiyev Ottumwa
i don't know who voted for me I know it
was very difficult to achieve a majority
but I do think today the most important
question was giving a speech which
reflected my convictions a pro-european
speech but in which there was an attempt
to find the solutions to the divisions
that exist between west and east and
south and north giving me confidence in
advance that I bridge the divisions we
do see definitely and that is what I
want to do I want to unite Europe I want
to bring Europe forward and if we want
to be successful in Europe we have to
stand together of course we will always
have differences of course we will
always have issues but we have to focus
on the big topics on the big questions
and that's my task Thomas Meyer Thomas
Meyer from standard for concerns
president in symphonies actor C
president designation you've said gee
you want to come to Cal with the
Parliament work hand in hand he said
that during your speech
what do you think about this
specifically your main thing first there
will be to put the Commission together
and to draw up a working program
personally do you want to bring the
Parliament into play in setting out the
working program what would that mean
specifically in terms of work bringing
together the heads of the the group
could that be perhaps difficult bringing
them in and getting them to work
alongside you
well the basic lines are in the
political guidelines and blind lines
they're very clear they need to be
worked and further over the last two
weeks I've worked very closely with with
everybody I needed to get to know people
to start off with I needed to look at
the different priorities and compare
them and see how they fitted in with my
convictions
and where we can move ahead together I
think it is a very important task in
this Parliament to be very transparent
to be very open to work very closely in
intensively alongside
political groups my parliamentary
experiences the more open you are the
closer you are to people the better your
work will be in difficult issues where
you need to work together and make
progress there where it's very hard to
get a majority appoint me well I'm
perhaps taking the view of Eastern
Europe congratulations first of all it's
a pleasure to hear so much French spoken
may be Europe's changing at any rate
I've got a question in respect of the
top jobs Eastern Europe has gone
completely forgotten how do you intend
to remedy that in the European
Commission perhaps with important
portfolios going to figures from Eastern
Europe or by some other means I'm
resolved says the president to find a
good geographic balance like everyone I
believe we must progress in recent
I've worked a great deal in Central
Europe and in the East I think there's a
lot of confidence as regards my way of
working which is very pragmatic we want
to resolve problems for me it's
important to identify commissioners
who will certainly have major portfolios
in order to make it clear that the east
and center of Europe are appropriately
represented yes please Marine marine
come from the Financial Times
congratulations Madam President your
majority is very narrow and it looks
like there is a contingent of Emmy piece
from the UK who would have been part of
that majority they may no longer be
around for the entire duration of your
mandate to ensure that you still have a
backing of a majority of the Parliament
when we have 27 member states would you
want to commit to real holding your vote
once the UK is no longer part of the EU
we're holding your vote I didn't I don't
I should have heard translation would
you would you would you be stand or
reconfirm your majority who wants the EU
consists of 27 member states to ensure
that this house fully in its majority is
still behind you it will not introduce
new roads now what I think what is my
crucial to be to be serious on that what
is one of the miles most noble and the
most crucial tasks I do have ahead of me
is you've sensed there is within the
political groups that decided the wins
for example they decided not to vote for
me today more openness today than it was
a week ago when you've been watching the
hearings you know that was improvement
and I accept they had to get to know me
they have to get to know me they have to
win confidence and they have to rely on
me so my work will be with the
pro-european
parties to work for stable majorities
you know that before I was in the game
it was also difficult to find a stable
platform majority but to proceed in this
work I think is of high importance and
crucial for the success we will have as
commission with the Parliament and with
the council but I know citavi
congratulations again and two questions
one are you envisaging a Commissioner
for the environment given your
commitment or the reduction of carbon
emissions in the future years one in two
apart from the environment what is going
to be the number one issue you're going
to address the first measure you're
going to take in the first two three
months of your mandate I said today that
we're gonna start a climate law within
the Green Deal for Europe what the the
the cabinet the college is concerned and
the portfolio's of the Commission's I
haven't done taken any kind of decision
right now
I was completely focused once again I
beg your pardon
13 days to plunge right into the topic
and to get things done as they are on
the table today I think it's worse to
look at the guidelines and I decided I
mean a few days ago we weren't sure at
all whether there would be a majority or
not so I really focused on this thing
and from right on now I'm going to focus
on developing the work program and to
put the Commission together but I
haven't thought at all about these
different pieces of the puzzle and the
two last questions first there please
Kathryn Puri you reporter
president-elect and will you I hate to
bring up the B word fact B words brexit
and Boris but are you looking forward to
working with Boris Johnson in future or
would you prefer to work with Jeremy
hunts on the future of UK's relationship
with the EU thank you I do not know both
of them personally and there is a golden
rule which I respect that I will work in
a very constructive way with every head
of state or government my other last one
I have a very general question to
conclude maybe a personal one too but
why exactly did you want this job from
the outset given specially given the
challenge that it represented for you
plain and simple because my I I was born
European and my my first as I grew up in
Brussels and as everything was European
at the very beginning and I come from a
family that has a European history it
was I always wanted to be back in the
European environment which was for me of
course then work here even the
Commission ORN and other places and
therefore after having of course made
quite some detours
by training I'm a medical doctor so I've
been working quite a while in the
medical field and I came pretty late
into politics I was beginning of 40s
when I started with politics it was an
enormous gift and I learned tremendously
during those now 13 years with Angela
Merkel in a cabinet but as I said I
always wanted to come back to my roots
and I'm very very happy to be here
Marat Fintan post Italy you talked a lot
of the intention of building a stronger
Europe does this mean that you won't
accept Eric sceptical commissioners
which could be proposed by nationalists
or populist government's around Europe
such as Italy for example thank you I
want a commission that is working to
strengthen Europe to position Europe in
this world in its appropriate role and
Europe is needed in this world and on
this within this difficult and changing
environment and I am deeply convinced
that we all do better when we work
better together all of us no 28 member
states that none of us on its own will
be as successful tackling the problems
as we are together
28 member states and this it's beauty
and the secret of Europe of course it's
sometimes tiring and to look for counted
for content and compromise is difficult
but in the very end we take 500 million
people along on this journey so I want a
commission that is totally dedicated on
improving the European Union of course
respecting subsidiarity this is saying
itself but in improving the European
Union as I'm convinced it's better for
the European people and the world needs
a strong assertive and active Europe the
composition of the Commission will will
how do you say be the right one for that
task thank you very much have a nice day
thank you
[Music]